al'approche de la saison du barbecue on
se demande souvent si notre appareil en
vaut encore la peine
l'épicerie a demandé aux spécialistes
christian massicotte d'étudier l'état de
trois barbecues au gaz afin de leur
donner un air de jeunesse
ou des pensées des immigrés à 1h
inoxydable
c'est sûr qu'ils viennent noah chacun
normalement la grille hannachi oxydable
si on la broque bien si on l'a eu il
qu'un concert le barbecue aventure est
quand même très longtemps la grille de
sa voix est une grille qui vote qui va
demander beaucoup plus d'entretiens avec
vraiment là lui à chaque fois qu'on est
terminée sinon qu'un confié après
diverses on n'a pas entretenu notre
grille on la ressent est tout rouillé
pas avoir des petites galettes qui
décolle avec mais par contre ça vaut
souvent la plaine d'inverser vendée
nouvelle grille parce que le reste
barbecue est bon
[Musique]
bon la plupart des barbecues maintenant
fait de la presque totalité ont ce qu'on
appelle des diffuseurs à l'époque on
mettait nos petites roches volcaniques
pineau petites briquettes en céramique
exact ça s'est fini c'est fini les mêmes
facturier ont abandonnés sont un peu
parce que dans la roche de la roche
volcanique était parole à l'absorber
beaucoup de bureaux puis un mandat libye
flammes étaient beaucoup plus présents
les manufacturiers de barbe est qu ont
adopté des plaques comme ça ça fait que
sa vie est d'abord à la voie des roches
poreuses
sur les plaques comme ça c'est un fait
en acier inoxydable c'est sûr que ça
vous un peu avec le teint mais un
clavier tant qu'elle est solide il n'y a
pas de travail pas de problème biographe
qui tombe dessus c'est ce qui produit
une fumée se serait que si on cuit un
température trop élevée pour ce qui suit
puis que beaucoup de grâce aux équipes à
avoir quand même des flambées mais c'est
moins problématique au niveau des plan a
b que les anciennes la joie tiennent
donc socke tant que c'est pas percevoir
en bas même c'est pas joli ça fait le
travail ça fait ça fait le travail
effectivement
pour s'assurer d'une bonne diffusion de
la chaleur on nettoie bien le fond afin
d'en retirer tous les débris
on peut ensuite utiliser un produit
dégraissant et rincez à l'eau pour
vérifier l'état de la cub
[Musique]
la pièce maîtresse d'un barbecue est
sans contredit le brûleur nous avons
demandé à luis desrosiers du service de
sécurité incendie de montréal de nous
parler des risques lors de l'utilisation
des appareils au gaz question vous a
apporté celui ci c'est justement parce
qu'il ya eu de la visite qui se sont
installés pour l'hiver et qu'un le
propriétaire à partie son barbecue la
flamme est sorti pas ici à tout brûle il
devint dû effectivement on voit qu'il me
manque un petit peu d'entre étiez vous
manque un petit peu d'amour donc
comprendre une brosse les brosses
d'acide qui ont convaincu estimant pour
nettoyer nous apparaît et on brosse nous
brûle et on s'assure que tout l'été
ouverture ne sont pas obstruée
on passe également une brosse à
l'intérieur des tubes de brûlures pour
éliminer d'éventuels nids d'insectes qui
pourrait causer un retour de flamme
on vérifie ensuite la qualité de la
planche on va regarder
si la flandre et les égale partout sur
le dollar si on voit qu'un plat ce
qu'est une flamme qui est très longue ça
peut être une indication que le brûleur
et rendu trop oublié puis qu'il s'est
formé un trou un clip troupes sont là
normalement
on constate ici que ce brûleur a connu
de meilleurs jours son remplacement est
inévitable
si les pièces d'origine sont facilement
accessibles on privilégie toujours les
pièces d'origine parce que les pièces
d'origine ont été
pensés pour la grandeur du barbecue pour
la bonne combustion du barbecue crise
parce que j'avais des brûlures
universelle avec ses poings vraiment
conçu spécifiquement pour votre appareil
ça va faire un à légère différence au
niveau de la combustion de
la répartition de la chaleur dans votre
barbecue
[Musique]
une bonne règle à suivre et d'évaluer le
coût des pièces de remplacement selon la
valeur d'achat de votre appareil dans
notre exemple l'état général du barbecue
justifie qu'on installe des pièces
d'origine puisque les pièces
universelles sont à prix comparable
[Musique]
un barbecue est une très grande source
de chaleur il ne faut donc pas négliger
le choix de son emplacement pour éviter
les mauvaises surprises mais d'être dans
un premier temps faut s'assurer que
l'appareil est bien placé bien situer
donc à une distance raisonnable bâtiment
ou de la structure où il est situé un
bond de pied il faut faire aussi une
certaine vérification au niveau de la
bonbonne puis des conduits de
raccordement effectivement fait une
solution d'eau savonneuse lions vont
ouvrir notre bouteille de propane pour
faire circuler le gaz à l'intérieur des
conduits à ce moment là si une fuite
faire des petites bulles avec le gaz qui
va sortir si on n'arrive pas en
resserrant le régulateur a enlevé ses
petites bulles l'homme à ce moment-là
faut quand même elles changent faudrait
voir à changer les pièces
il est important de rappeler une règle
élémentaire lorsqu'on allume le barbecue
on s'assure bien entendu que le
couvercle est levé avant d'ouvrir notre
bouteille de propane on ouvre notre
propane on allume nos brûlures puis on
essaie de le faire percer avec notre
animal ça ne fonctionne pas on n'attend
pas de minutes
on referme on attend que ça se dissipe
puis après on prend un allumeur
idéalement avec un long bout pas un
petit briquet parce que ça nous laisse
peu d'amplitude pour partir puis on
risque de brûler de nous brûler les
mains
les gens se rend pas compte à quel point
le gaz peut s'accumuler en très peu de
temps et pu faire en sorte que vous vous
trouviez pas de soucis et postule
effectivement parce que le gaz s'est
accumulé et par le temps qu'on
on va chercher notre briquet ou comprend
des briquets auto et qu'on arrive la
gaze et déjà accumulé en grande surface
[Musique]
un bon entretien et de la prudence et
vous pourrez profiter d'une autre belle
saison de grillades en toute quiétude